merci merci de votre présence merci
beaucoup pour votre présence et merci à
toute l'équipe du tad qui a permis cette
rencontre et ses rencontres en général
alors vous savez déjà de quoi je vais
vous parler c'est écrit derrière
pas de surprise est-ce que vous ne
voudriez pas pratique et plutôt
qu'entendre parler à ça ça fait plaisir
sinon j'aurais été embêté un petit peu
en fait à vrai dire
donc là de la méditation n'est pas n'est
pas compliqué du tout je suis persuadé
que certains d'entre vous ont déjà fait
l'expérience
en fait il suffit de trouver une
méditation qui soit adaptée à chacun qui
sont agréables et confortables
on commence alors première étape c'est
le confort alors assurez vous que vous
êtes en plein confort c'est super ce
m
est ce qu'on peut avoir des spots un peu
moins fort que la force eut bien sûr la
figure ça ce voit la super alors le
confort c'est un peu tous et là ce sont
les fringues est-ce que ça sert est-ce
que ça sert pas c'est la bonne distance
avec le voisin ou la voisine
alors on vient de parler à la pause on
vient d'être enthousiaste pour un film
maintenant je vais vous proposer de
regarder à l'intérieur de vous alors
encore une fois la première étape c'est
la conscience corporelle
ensuite vous pouvez fermer les yeux si
vous voulez on peut fermer les yeux
et qu'est ce qui se passe quand on est
pleinement conscient pleinement éveillé
et qu'on ferme les yeux
qu'est ce qui se passe en nous on va
simplement observer sans aucun jugement
n'y a pas de bon ou de mal on va
simplement observé faisant l'expérience
ensemble et on va commencer par la
respiration être conscient de la
respiration sans chercher à changer la
respiration
on va observer vraiment sa part du
ventre
ni avec la pause est très apprécié et je
crois que je peux partir
on va observer aussi le circuit de l'air
de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur de
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur
observez la respiration observer le
circuit de l'air le mouvement de l'air
maintenant on va porter l'attention ou
le sommet du crâne calais le corps petit
à petit et en scannant le corps ont
pourtant notre attention dans le corps
ont des temps le corps donc on part du
sommet de la tête et on descend et on
porte simplement notre attention sur la
tête toute ma tête
le crâne le coup les joues les yeux la
bouche la langue les mâchoires ont des
temps on observe et en étant observé en
des temps où c'est simple on pense aux
épaules ont des sports attention demain
dans les épaules le cou et le thorax le
dos toute la colonne vertébrale les bras
la poitrine le plexus solaire ont fait
tout le tour du plexus solaire comme une
ceinture
c'est là où se trouve notre beaucoup de
stress beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup de
d'autodiscipline ont des temps on perd
notre attention des temps des temps le
ventre
on va à l'intérieur du ventre sur les
côtés derrière devant une zone où il ya
beaucoup d'émotions de mémoire de
souvenirs
on pour notre attention des temps les
jambes on est en tout les jambes
jusqu'aux pierre
et on sent particulièrement les pieds on
poste bien ses pieds on sent la terre on
sent le poids du corps et la connexion
avec le sol
et maintenant on va porter notre
attention au centre de la poitrine
imaginons qu'il ya une lumière un soleil
un soleil plein de lumière et plein de
chaleur simplement imaginer qu'on a un
soleil au centre de la poitrine plein de
lumière de chaleur et on va c'est juste
développer ce sentiment
plus de lumière plus de chaleur plus de
lumière plus de chaleur
maintenant on a cette chaleur dans toute
la poitrine
et on fait monter cette lumière et cette
chaleur dans le court dans le visage que
ça illumine notre sourire les yeux tout
la tête plein de lumière de notre
lumière intérieure que l'on imagine ou
que l'on ressent
et maintenant tout le corps tout le
corps lumineux et chaud de notre propre
lumière intérieure
toute la pièce
toute cette salle
et bien au delà imaginait jusqu'aux
confins du cosmos on a eu quelques
clichés tout à l'heure allons
ne soyons pas timide on peut rayonner à
partir d'ici jusqu'aux confins du cosmos
pas de souci c'est possible
et on va aussi aller trouver ce un
sentiment de bien-être comme si on était
un acteur ou une actrice allons chercher
en nous un sentiment je suis bien je me
sens bien
mon corps est détendu je respire sans
tension je me sens bien parce que je
choisis de me sentir bien et quelque
chose en moins qui est très profond
rayonne très au delà très loin le plus
loin possible et maintenant continuer
l'exploration
on va faire monter notre attention dans
le cerveau dans la tour de contrôle
observez les pensées penser qu'ils
dirigent tous dans notre vie
consciemment ou inconsciemment on
devrait être on devrait pouvoir prendre
un papier un crayon on va pas le faire
maintenant on devrait pouvoir prendre un
papier un crayon et dire voilà je suis
devant l'écran de mon mental qu'est-ce
qui va apparaître
quels sont les pensées qui vont
apparaître voilà j'ai pensé à ça ah
tiens je n'étais pas attentif quelque
chose s'est passé qui m'a échappé
je reviens à ma concentration
je regarde je suis assis devant l'écran
de mon mental qu'est ce qui se passe
sans jugement sans critique
ce
alors maintenant que je vous ai donné
des guidances j'ai fait une méditation
guidée je vous laisse un peu libre de
votre créativité de ce qui vient vous
pouvez jouer revenir sur les perceptions
physiques corporelle revenir sur la
respiration développer le rayonnement du
coeur si vous êtes plus attirés dans ce
domaine développer la concentration dans
le mental c'est ce qui vous parle le
plus
aller chercher des émotions de bien-être
si c'est ça qui vous parle le plus
prenez ce moment de liberté
où il ya une collaboration entre la
guide ans et votre créative et
créativité personnelle c'est ce qu'on a
parlé dans dans la conférence précédente
jouer amusant non
et
et puis lu lentement on va revenir de
cette concentration de cette méditation
à votre rythme tranquillement pour qu'on
garde tous les bénéfices et qu'on
revienne à ouvrir les yeux à votre
rythme et revenir ici tout en gardant de
la relaxation du bien-être super c'est
facile je vois des visages différents
vous voyez que c'est on ne fait pas
appel à une croyance par une forme de
religion c'est quelque chose qui est en
nous en permanence ça veut dire qu'on
est en permanence on est en permanence
le pouvoir avec nous de nous sentir
détendu conscient je voudrais vous dire
aussi en quelques mots à quoi ça sert
comme comme je vous disais il n'y a pas
plus puissant que nos pensées qu'elles
soient conscientes ou inconscientes donc
cette forme de méditation va permettre
de passer le ce qui est inconscient vers
le conscient si je m'observe sans juger
mais penser au jour le jour je vais voir
mes structure psychologique
je vais voir mon stress avant d'aller à
un entretien d'embauché
je vais je vais voir mes tensions quand
j'avais un rendez-vous quand je vais
voir ma famille quand je vois mes amis
quand je vais au travail qui se
manifeste dans pensez donc si je si je
suis capable de prendre un petit pas de
recul et de dire ah tiens mais pourquoi
je m'imagine en train en train d'échouer
je vais un entretien en poche mais déjà
je me dis ils ont une pile de cv c'est
pas possible de toute façon j'ai pas
j'ai pas les compétences et à linverse
il a des gens qui ont un inconscient qui
est un bon formatage c'est pour ça qu'on
parle d'eux c'est un peu similaire à un
ordinateur et qui qui vont confiant un
entretien d'embauché qui s'imagine déjà
en train de réussir
donc ça c'est une forme d'auto analyse
et d'autopsié psychothérapie qui va
permettre vraiment de faire le clair de
mettre au clair beaucoup de choses en
nous même si je prends si je prends un
exemple je suis ici de métaphores la
plupart du temps dans notre vie on est
un petit peu quand on vit dans un
appartement dans une maison et on est à
la fenêtre à la fenêtre ce sont les sens
on est connecté au sens on est à
l'extérieur à la fenêtre et on regarde
ce qui se passe on est très excités par
la nature les animaux qui équipe assez
les gens qui passent et c'est beaucoup
beaucoup c'est très excitant que ça nous
fait un peu oublier ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur donc la méditation c'est
reculait de tu de l'excitation
sensorielle et prendre conscience de ce
qui est autour de nous et autour de nous
donc c'est une chambre d'un appartement
une maison et la méditation va permettre
de ranger de mettre en ordre de mettre
au clair et donc on va devenir plus
ordonné plus efficace plus
positif plus d'énergie en général c'est
ce que moi la méditation m'a apporté en
premier donc un développement personnel
individuel qui est très très fort
ensuite qu'est ce qui se passe on rentre
dans le plus subtil imaginons que que
dans cet appartement
justement on arrête la télévision on
arrête la radio qu'est ce qui se passe
on va entendre ce qui vient ce qui vient
depuis l'extérieur
donc on va attendre peut-être le bruit
du ruisseau où le bruit ou le bruit de
la rue et on va écouter encore un petit
peu plus et on va entendre les oiseaux
ou des sont de plus en plus subtile de
plus en plus subtile de plus en plus
subtile et c'est simplement ce qui se
fait pour les gens climatique qui
pratique la méditation et les gens qui
pratique la méditation de façon suivie
voit tout se développer des talents
certains se met à peindre certains se
mettent à avoir une empathie une
compassion avoir une qualité d'écouté
etc etc
chacun est très individuelle dans ce cas
là mais c'est comme si on se rapprochait
de quelque chose en nous qui est plus
grand et plus vaste et ça ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas du tout du mysticisme ce
n'est pas extraordinaire c'est ce qui
nous appartient à tous et chacun sait
simplement que notre culture ne nous a
pas éduqué al ça nous a pas appris à
regarder à l'intérieur on est très
éduqués pour faire de la gym et pour
pour acquérir de nouveaux de nouvelles
compétences
on est capable de beaucoup d'efforts
mais cette forme de pratique avant est
une puissance d'une simplicité que je
vous invite à découvrir et à explorer
voilà pour ce soir merci